all the work we do at tpb is oriented
around how do we change systems of
production on planet earth so that we
can make things using less energy less
land less natural resources
i'm a big believer that sustainability
in the 21st century does not arise from
convincing consumers to consume less i
think sustainability arises from
building technology-based solutions that
let consumers consume more
and dropping the price and dropping the
environmental impact and that's what
technology allows us to do so if you go
back to the industrial revolutions you
know of the 19th and 20th century we
built factories right we put all this
technology in a big machine and a big
facility and we used it to make stuff
over and over again and that dropped the
price for consumers because we automated
in a big factory turns out that the
technology of that factory as all
technology does
shrinks
gets faster gets cheaper gets better
[Music]
let me brag about you for a second
because you're not a very
you're a very humble guy you're not a
very bragworthy guy
when i first started hearing you talk um
which was not on the all-in podcast i
went on youtube and i heard you give a
talk back when you were doing climate
corporation
and i remember thinking this guy's
pretty smart um you're giving a talk at
some school i don't know what it was and
i started googling you then and saw wow
this guy's actually
he did that and then he did some
impressive stuff since then so let me
just brag on you for a second so you
were
at google 2004 2006 some some range like
that so
fairly early at google like i think
that's like around the ipo time that's
just post ipo is that right
uh i joined probably seven months before
the ipo so
yeah we were working on the ipo or just
started working on the ipo when i joined
and then uh then you do climate
corporation sell that for like a billion
dollars to monsanto you do metro mile
which is a pretty cool insurance company
that's backed and then i think
ultimately ended up selling
for a little less than it's back for to
uh lemonade and then
um then you have this thing called tpb
so the production board and in that
you're basically what do you call it a
studio or uh what do you call kind of
well yeah we're technically a holding
company and our you know and we're a
foundry so we spend time kind of doing r
d and and research and and founding or
building businesses so we kind of call
it a foundry
and i feel like people know you know we
do we do some investing as well but
really our focus is on foundry work um i
want to start with this you
are known for
you know being a sort of a scientist or
a science guy but i looked at your
linkedin and your first job was
investment banker so where did how did
you go from investment banker to uh as
you're called on the all-in-one the
sultan of science
well i went to school at uc berkeley my
major was astrophysics i spent some time
as an intern at the lawrence berkeley
national lab
which is a department of energy physics
lab up the hill from from uc berkeley
and i spent
you know a lot of time doing
mathematical modeling of
stuff in a basement
and generally found it to be kind of
just pretty disparaging in the sense
that like you could spend years working
on a project that never sees the light
of day
at the same time that i was at school
the dot-com bubble was kind of you know
blowing up all around me i mean there
was even a kid in my dorm
who started a company selling dvds
online and sold the business for a
million bucks and that was such an
amazing thing to happen
you know i was mostly making money by
playing poker and working you know jobs
around school and getting paid for my
internship and stuff
so you know it was extraordinary kind of
seeing just in the bay area the world
changing because of the internet
and so i got really kind of inclined and
interested in
not going to grad school and really
going to go work in silicon valley so i
you know i applied for a bunch of
investment banking jobs that was kind of
the hot job to get out of school where i
could focus on the tech industry and
learn about it
and um you know i guess i had never
taken a finance accounting business
class and so i guess my poker experience
paid off because that's how i put that
on my resume i got a bunch of interviews
and
i ended up getting a job working in a
technology investment bank so focused on
the tech industry and so i got to work
with
lots of tech companies for a two-year
analyst program while i was there and
learned about business and finance and
so on
so that was kind of my first foray
you know into the world of business i
tried to start a business when i was in
college
never really talked about this publicly
raised some money from some family
members some friends of the family but
never really did anything with it never
really got off the ground it was um the
idea was to let you buy all of your
telecommunications services on a website
so you're you know everything from your
cell phone build your
you know your long distance provider
which was kind of important at the time
and so on
so
what'd you get wrong with that because
that's actually not a bad idea
especially during that time uh was
i don't think it was probably the idea
you just did not know
i still have the business plan i keep it
in my office i printed it up like from
1999 or 2000.
as a reminder or what yeah as a reminder
it was
originally called
and telebomb.com i renamed it in phone
services and i registered it i set up a
wells fargo account
um there was a whole uh
experience of starting a business
um
and yeah i mean ultimately i kind of got
caught up in
trying to get a job out of school and um
and you know transition to
to focus on on you know what's next in
my life and then you know before i
joined google i started another business
which was kind of like a research q a
site online
called kadanga k-a-d-a-n-g-a-kadanga.com
so i basically taught myself like
php and javascript and html and css and
i programmed the whole site myself
and um
and
mysql and i basically
set up my own server and registered the
domain and set up bank accounts and it
actually made money
and so you know i advertised on adwords
and i got users to come to the website
and ask questions and get answers and
they'd pay for the the answers
um and so that actually helped me
ultimately get my job at google because
i had all this experience you know i was
coding on my own until like five in the
morning and then go to work at seven a.m
and so like building this service and
building this whole site it actually
google had a service at the time called
like google research or something i
forgot what it was called but it was
very similar to this and so i got the
job at google i think in part because of
that experience so when you were doing
that you were uh
like okay listen today i think you've
built companies i'm just gonna use round
numbers uh you know you can correct me
if i'm way off but you've built
companies now that i think in aggregate
have are worth more than two and a half
billion dollars now if if i went and i
told you when you were building kandanga
or you're you know you're in college and
i said you know
hey that could that's something that
could happen would you have been
surprised was that even an ambition of
yours were you even would you have been
shocked that that's even possible or
were you like oh it all worked my plan
could have worked if i told you that
that's how it played out
um
no i don't think i would have thought
about it in that framework probably
would have been disappointed uh if i
think about it
um
i i still am generally i fee i guess you
know maybe ambition
um
is uh
you know an expectations i set for
myself probably greater than um
than what i've experienced but um i
would say that you know my intention
wasn't started for a second so you're
saying you're a college kid and you had
expectations of yourself
that grand do you remember kind of what
you were thinking back then
um not specifically i mean i just feel
like when you're young you have kind of
unbounded ambition i mean you don't know
the realities of
you know when you build stuff and you
face challenges and you face hiccups and
you know everything from team to
technology to markets and all the issues
that arise
as you navigate your way through
complexity and uncertainty
uh you're naive in the sense that like
the whole world can and should be
different so we should change the whole
world and let's go fix it make it
different make it better
and you know that blind optimism is
where a lot of energy comes from that i
think drives great entrepreneurial
success stories
ultimately you know there's friction and
rubber hits the road and
um you know in retrospect i think a lot
of what's gone on in my life and my
career is probably understandable um in
hindsight but you know blind ambition
gives you unlimited um a vision and i
think uh
uh you know if if you're not
if you're not challenged along the way
you know that that that can and should
persist um you know but i would say that
my my orientation was never about
starting a bunch of companies or making
a bunch of money it was um you know much
more about kind of impact and um
and so
you know and solving big problems and
having great breakthroughs and seeing
those breakthroughs really change the
world and that's still i think really
core to my sense of of energy and things
that i do
and we were at google
at a time google was very ambitious
and uh i think i've read or heard
basically like larry page is kind of a
fan of yours i think he's invested in
tpb and it sounds like you were there
and
you were doing corp dev there so so you
were doing a kind of different role
what was give me a google story what was
it like at that time what was it like
around those founders
give me a sort of a story around
ambition or your time at google well um
so i joined google uh there was just
under a thousand people i believe and um
you know we all kind of worked pretty
close together there was like two
buildings or three buildings um that
that were the main buildings at campus
there
at 1600 amphitheater
and um
you know so
when i joined uh there was three of us
that started this corporate development
group which was really like what's the
strategy and things we can acquire and
invest in and grow the business
and had pretty kind of free reign to
look at things and i really focused on
kind of the advertiser or business side
of google so i wasn't interested in
consumer products i was more interested
in like what's our business
and so you know in that context i worked
on all sorts of ideas of like how do we
take what we offer advertisers which at
the time was really just adwords and how
do we think about other media we can
make advertising available to those
advertisers so you know can we do print
ads can we do radio ads can we do tv ads
can our advertisers use adwords as an
interface to access media across all
these different properties and channels
so i did a few acquisitions and found a
few companies one was called dmarc that
we turned into kind of this radio
advertising business so you could go to
adwords and click on audio ads and
create an audio ad and then publish it
to actual radio stations then it would
play in stream and radio stations and
you could see the impressions and all
this stuff that's um not a thing now
right that didn't that didn't end up
becoming
part of that it stayed for a long time
um they ended up being a really nasty
lawsuit with the founders and a very
difficult
um set of circumstances that arose after
the acquisition i mean i'll tell you
uh this story now given how many years
it's been i think that was 15 16 17
years ago holy 17 years ago at this
point
but you know i had real issues with
negotiating with the founders and doing
the transaction
and you know we thought it was such a
great plug and play for google these
guys went out and all djs and radio
stations
buy these servers that they put into the
um the radio station and they and they
put the mp3 files of the ads on the
servers at midnight every night and then
when the dj says okay time for reading
for ads they press the play button and
starts playing the ads off the server so
what these guys did is they bought the
company that has all those servers for
like four million dollars and they
connected it to the internet and they
set it up so that advertisers could
remotely create dynamic content and fill
in the unsold ad spots on that server
every night at midnight and so they were
buying what's called remnant inventory
and making money on it and so it was
brilliant but for the four million
dollar acquisition and not a lot of
technology development thereafter you
know they were trying to sell the
business to us for 100 million dollars
so they thought it was worth a billion i
mean the whole thing was crazy how we
negotiated the deal so it ended up being
like effectively a 50 million dollar 75
72 million upfront cash payment a 50
million dollar milestone payment if they
hit a bunch of technical milestones and
then up to 1.2 billion dollars in earn
outs based on the advertising revenue
generated from all these stations and so
that earn out structure was the only way
i could really bridge the gap on the
deal i had to go talk to google's board
about it we eventually got them to sign
off on it and the whole thing ended up
being like a really ugly
uh negotiation and i didn't want to do
the deal and i told eric schmidt i'm
like look i don't think we should do
this deal i don't think these guys are
going to work out for us i think it's
going to be ugly and eric said we have
to be in radio it's a 60 billion market
push the whole thing through despite my
push against it we did the deal
and uh sure enough we ended up in this
nasty lawsuit that lasted for years i
wasn't around for all that but um
you know i think eventually it all went
away and audio ads kind of kind of died
down so that was the sort of stuff i
also worked on google analytics so i
pitched larry and sergey early on and
the idea of like
look our advertisers should be able to
have analytics on their web pages to see
you know how people are converting and
why and why not we didn't have a
conversion tracker at the time or
anything
so um you know
what that means i pitched larry and
sergey so like you know larry and sergey
are the founders of google there so i i
work i work with an amazing person named
megan smith she's really well known in
silicon valley she was obama's cto um uh
she's um she's an incredible personality
and a tour de force and megan was really
my mentor at google and kind of showed
me how i can just walk into larry and
sergey's office and walk in eric's
obviously like let's go talk to them
about this and i'd be talking about like
let's go see what eric thinks and she'd
drag me over to eric's office and he'd
be like sitting there on his computer
doing emails and she'd like barge in and
be like david's got this idea let's talk
about it and then like sit down and you
know like and so she really kind of
showed me that we can and should have
this kind of dialogue with these execs
because our job was to really help push
and think about things that we can
take google you know what direction we
can take google
and so you know i really um
had i think great mentorship there and
so i you know uh was in a meeting with
larry and sergey saying like i think we
should be in
analytics and we should offer
advertisers the ability to see stuff and
i met wesley chan who was a product
manager at the time and so wesley and i
um
kind of started working together after
that because the first thing larry and
sergey said to me was that's evil
third-party cookies are evil we don't
want to track users across different web
pages and you know because then they'll
know that we're tracking them and so it
was fairly prescient at the time that
larry and sergey saw that this might be
kind of an evil or viewed evilly by kind
of consumers down the road and they were
absolutely right i mean that's what's
going on in the eu and and with apple
and facebook and all the cookie tracking
and so on that's being kind of taken
apart right now
um but we showed them that like look if
an advertiser can get analytics they can
see an incredible improvement in
conversion efficiency which means that
the user is having a better experience
on the web page so rather than the user
getting frustrated and leaving the
website wasting their time if the user
is happy the user will buy more they
will convert better and the internet is
a better place one of our guiding
principles at adwords was like our
advertisements should be so good and the
and the advertiser's website should be
so good that 100 of the time when people
are looking at search results they click
on the first ad and then 100 of the time
they don't come back so the bounce back
rate is zero and that shows you that
you've shown the perfect ad that's even
better than the organic search results
and it's such a good result that the
consumer stays there all the way and
never comes back and searches again so
that's kind of the guiding principle so
everything is all about how do you
improve the quality of the ads how do
you improve the user's experience when
they go to the advertiser's site and how
do you get the advertiser to pay for
that value
um and so analytics ultimately turned
into you know we found a company called
urchin i took wesley to ses search
engine strategies we walked around we
met a bunch of analytics companies we
met had four of them come in and talk to
us and we picked urchin and convinced
them to to join convince larry and
sergey to do the deal within a year i
think we had shown
through hal varian who was our chief
economist we had demonstrated that
google analytics increased adwords
revenue by half a billion dollars
because it it so many advertisers were
using it to improve their websites and
make the conversions better that they
were spending more on adwords and so you
could kind of economically show the
benefit of analytics and that was like a
25 million dollar acquisition so it
turned into a great product i mean i
don't know any web pages that don't have
you know google analytics on them
you're like where's my bonus
it was all good the um
yeah i mean if you could if you can show
that all right i'm buying a visitor it
takes me it cost me a dollar to get the
click but now that i can improve my
funnel so that that customer is worth
more to me i can convert more of those
customers then i'll spend more right
like that exactly
and the customer's happier because
people are going to a web page that gets
them what they want as opposed to going
to a web page and getting lost in the
content not clicking through and buying
dead end so and my last google question
you know when we got acquired i got
acquired by twitch which is like a part
of amazon
and i remember like the first or second
meeting where it was like you know all
the kind of exact same room and as a
startup founder i remember
always feeling
a little bit not like impostor syndrome
but sort of always curious like this is
how i lead the company i have no idea
how anyone else does it right even my
founder friends i don't actually get to
see them in meetings so i really had no
idea what they were doing in my first
meeting at twitch i remember looking at
emmett who's somebody i really respect
uh who's kind of my boss he's the
original founder
and he was sitting there and like
there's whatever 20 people in the room
and somebody presents like this six page
paper
and i remember uh he was like done
reading it in like half the time of
anybody else and then he had like
scribbled down some questions on it and
then the first question he asked like
cut straight to the heart of the thing
and i remember just thinking oh this
this is what it would be like if my
brain was twice the size like oh i could
read twice as fast i could get to the
heart of the issue you know twice as
fast and i was just so impressed by him
you know i think that great great
leaders in some ways almost feel like
aliens uh they sort of can they have
some superpowers that that others don't
and uh what was it like with the google
founders do you like were they just
normal people to you or did you notice
any special traits or sort of abilities
that impressed you at the time or made
an impression on you
no i mean look um
you know the culture is set at the top
and um the team that larry and sergey
built around them
uh you know remain some of the most
important and impactful people in
silicon valley um
you know susan wichiki
solar common gar um
earth is still svp of engineering there
he built all of the data center
infrastructure which by the way i don't
think a lot of people realize
um is probably the core advantage of
google uh or was originally like tell me
about this my co-founder who's super
technical of my past company he used to
say that he goes people don't ever talk
about this but it was google's server
architecture or their choices
that like allowed them to win what did
that mean yeah i never got to answer it
yeah so so if you go back to 1999 1998
right um in order to search the web you
have to have what are called web
crawlers so these are servers that are
going out and scanning all the web pages
on the internet and then indexing
servers and then your web servers which
are you know your indexing servers take
all that data and classify and organize
it and figure out what you know what
what's the search term that each web
page can represent and then fi and
what's the ranking that would that would
show up and then finally is these web
servers which is the the website
you know serving um servers so when you
go to google.com and do a search
and so you know in order to search the
web extensively and to have a high
refresh rate so how much of the web can
you search you have to have more servers
in order to search it more frequently
you have to have more servers so at the
time everyone was using kind of oracle
servers that cost like 3 000 bucks
and they had a pretty case and they had
purple on them and they used a lot of
power and they looked really nice and
they would last forever you know all
those kind of nonsense claims
and so google set out to basically build
a really cheap web server or really
cheap web crawling server and indexing
service they built their own servers by
taking commodity hardware and basically
breadboarding this thing so taking super
cheap ram super cheap hard drives
jamming them all on
not even putting a case or a cover on
i'm using super cheap power supplies no
problem and then they said they said
look no purple no casing and they made
them redundant and they're like look
we'll make lots of these we'll be able
to search more of the web we'll be able
to have a higher refresh rate and we'll
be able to index stuff better and have a
bigger index than anyone else because
we're making it so cheap to do this and
so their cost was like 150 200 instead
of 3 000
their servers broke every couple of
months but guess what it was so cheap to
make it when it broke they threw the
thing away and so it didn't matter they
didn't need to have a five-year server
they didn't need to have a high
performance server they didn't have the
fastest cpu and in fact when i joined
google they had a team that was working
on a 10 000 port switch
so you know
and and they were making their own asics
to do that their own chips and so the
depth that the um hardware engineering
team went into the data center and
infrastructure engineering team went
into at google to create a full stack of
technology that was advantaged from the
ground up meant that they would always
be able to search more of the internet
always be able to do it better always be
able to do it faster always be able to
have a higher refresh rate and that
advantage and then they made their
website super simple and they didn't
have to sell ads against it because it
cost so little to run the website
and so you add all that up and they
create this huge advantage this huge
structural moat more people come the
network effect more people show up
they've now got more people that they
can sell ads to they can now reinvest in
building more servers search more of the
web and so on and so forth
and then you know the adwords
architecture was just perfect it was an
auction and so advertisers would bid for
search terms they wouldn't do paid
insertion or paid inclusion which was
big at the time they said that's evil so
we'll show ads really clearly and
cleanly on the side and if you just want
to click on an ad they know they're
clicking on an ad and otherwise they
search the internet and it just created
this this this unparalleled mode and so
the hardware advantage that google built
from the beginning i think was really
core to their their point of success um
and and so sorry going back to your
question look larry's page is one of the
most impressive individuals you'll ever
meet it's really sad he's not more
public because i think larry could offer
a lot to the world in the way he thinks
and the way he talks about things um he
always takes a bigger point of view and
a bigger picture uh perspective on
things you know when when people would
suggest products or ideas he wouldn't
get into the technical details of the
near-term roadmaps he would always zoom
out 100x and be like why can't we do x
so you know why don't we search all the
world's books was one of the things they
proposed doing in 2003 which was a crazy
concept but they actually went and then
did it right and no one would have done
that if not for that suggestion that
that audacity of perspective and so they
always pushed and challenged every team
to think bigger to think more
grand to think um
more aggressively and i think that's a
common trait with great leaders and
technology businesses
is you know um uh and same with coaches
on sports teams you know your team is
only as good as you challenge them to be
and so they'll um you know if you're not
challenging your team and you're asking
them what do you think you can do
they're they're only going to achieve a
fraction of what's possible uh great
coaches and great leaders need to kind
of and technology leaders in particular
have this unique ability to i think
understand the technology and leap
several
iterations forward to speak to the team
about where we're headed and then bring
the timelines in and that makes for you
know an incredible sense of urgency and
outcome and why do you think most people
don't do that so thinking big that
sounds easy enough to understand sounds
fun to do
um
you know i could hear that advice why do
you think that's hard advice to follow
in practice it's a really important
question um so one of our principles at
tpb is dare to dream so it's all about
creating that audacious perspective you
know how big can this be how big should
we be
and um what happens when you set a big
goal like let's say i have to go climb
to the the top of a mountain and i can't
see the path from here to the top of the
mountain
um there's a hundred uh permutations or
a thousand permutations on how you might
get up that mountain and you don't know
which path is gonna work most people
that are smart have been successful and
most people that have been successful
are not used to not succeeding and so
the orientation at that point is that
success is all about doing something and
getting an action that you expect out of
what you just did and so you want you
are inclined naturally as a smart person
as a successful person to only do things
that you know what you're gonna get as
an outcome and guess what that does that
limits your horizon so then you end up
saying i'm not going to take the more
circuitous challenging route or path
that might get me to the top of the
mountain but i can see that this
particular path gets me you know a
quarter of the way up the mountain and
that may not and you might know however
that that means you're giving up going
to the top of the mountain but at least
you know for sure that if you do x
you're going to get y and i see this all
the time i see this all the time at
businesses
where the teams end up compromising on
their big vision and they compromise on
the moonshot because they're more likely
to succeed and they feel more
comfortable
taking a shorter range narrower horizon
and minimizing the opportunity set
significantly and saying i'm just going
to go do this because i know if i do x
i'm going to get y and that feels
comfortable and i know it's going to
happen and so they minimize the dare to
dream circumstance and then they always
say well you know what we'll come back
and dream big later but guess what
happens let's say you're thinking about
um i'll give you a very specific example
because this relates to
the business we're announcing this week
canada.com which is our our molecular
beverage printer but early on there was
a hard push to say look we know
restaurant owners will buy this device i
don't know if every consumer is going to
buy this device it might be too
expensive it might not taste good enough
consumers are so you know fickle if we
make a device for restaurants we know
that there's an economic advantage
there's an roi enterprise based sale
let's go sell in restaurants and we'll
make a bigger device so it can hold more
and we don't have to worry about
shrinking and getting all the technology
into a tiny form factor that fits on a
kitchen countertop
the problem is if you do that and you
start selling to restaurants
you've now significantly minimized the
opportunity to go into the consumer
channel because you now have a customer
and the customer is the restaurant and
the restaurant's going to say i want
this feature and i want this feature and
i want this feature i want you to do
this for me and all of a sudden your
whole team is going to be inundated with
product and feature requests that focus
on that much smaller much narrower
market you're going to end up going
deeper and deeper into that market and
you're gonna lose out on the opportunity
to go build for the big market to go
build for the 100x market that can
actually change the world and improve
the you know the the problems that we're
trying to address with this business and
so you know i've seen this at many
different businesses where taking on a
lot of technical risk taking on a
moonshot project um is often foregone
and you end up you know trading into a
much smaller pie and a much smaller
opportunity and then you often miss out
on that bigger opportunity and so i i
think it's really important for
entrepreneurs to continue to dream big
and find align capital and align
shareholders to let you dream big and
shoot for those bigger higher risk
opportunities because if they work
they're 100 expect
i um couldn't agree more i can think of
two examples in my own career where i'm
guilty of that where we did that and i
was just talking to a company i invested
that they pitched me this
amazing self-driving car uh you know
single person pat single single
passenger vehicles that were electric
and self-driving and it was this really
fantastic vision of what the future
might look like and i feel like you know
in many ways
they've made a lot of progress but also
uh it's they did the restaurant thing
basically they found a customer who
showed them a near path to like some
validation and in doing that they sort
of beat down the vision and sort of
tried tried to cram the vision into it
okay some of the vision doesn't fit here
all right it's just gonna get sort of
left behind and we'll just do this one
thing that might actually net be a much
smaller overall opportunity and smaller
impact
of this really hard technical thing if
you're going to spend your whole life
doing this well you know why not go for
the one that that actually might work
this also isn't limited to technical
have you heard the the airbnb uh brian
chesky's thing like the 12 star
experience have you heard this
no maybe uh but
you'll like this so so basically he sat
down his team he's like okay you know
we're in the hospitality business we
want to give our guests a great
experience a five-star experience he's
like so first let's just define it right
like what's a
you know just humor what's a one-star
experience it's like ah you get to the
house it's locked you know there's
cockroaches outside you know you can't
get in you're out in the cold blah blah
he's like be vivid about it so he made
them sort of explain really what that
one-star experience would feel like
then he's like all right give me a
three-star experience give me a
five-star experience and then the team
gets gets excited they say oh five-star
experience is you know you get there uh
it's easy to get in the place is nice it
looks just like the photos and you have
a great stay everything works nothing
breaks and you know on the way out you
know
the host leaves you a nice little gift
basket so so you enjoy yourself
he's like awesome
so what's a seven star experience
and now the team's sort of like you know
you see everyone tighten up it's like
they didn't expect that they already had
they thought five was the max number of
stars that you can have and he's like
right totally so give me more and
they're like well i guess you could get
there and there's somebody at the
airport to pick you up they got your
name on asani he's like yes give me more
and so they started to define a seven
star and he kept pushing it nine star 10
star 12 star and they get to this
ridiculous extreme of like
you know you get there not only do you
they have the stay they say hey you're
going to be up at 9am tomorrow i got
something special for you somebody picks
you up they take you on an adventure
surfing outside because they're an
expert and blah blah and then
that type of thinking is what gets you
to do airbnb experiences which is like
the local kind of like activities to go
do which wouldn't have really otherwise
been in a uh you know go book a place to
stay a place to sleep like type of
website necessarily right and so you can
do that on user experience and customer
experience just as much as you can do on
the technical side um i think that pairs
pretty well with your framework there
totally um so let's talk about canna
this is cool so i heard this this is
actually when i i think i reached out to
somebody on your team i said i wanna i
actually didn't want you on the pod i
said i wanna make a drink and so let's
can i explain it in simple terms of what
i think it is and then you correct me uh
go for it all right so
uh
you basically made a printer
like a home printer but instead of
printing out you know sheets of paper
with ink on it you could print out a
drink any drink so like for example my
wife is vegan she doesn't drink alcohol
never has drink you know a drop in her
life but she loves you know certain
types of teas and coffees and things
like that
and so she could take her favorite tea
and have it like exactly the way she
wants it so you know like one of the
reasons she loves starbucks is because
she can go in and say i wanna light ice
oat milk you know decaf with no sugar
blah blah blah she can customize her
whole drink so similarly we're gonna
have a device and you know if i fast
forward 10 15 years i don't know you
tell me the timeline but we're gonna
have a device in our house that we can
just push a button and it'll dispense
the drink we want it'll print a drink
for you that is exactly the drink you
want and that same machine that she's
going to use for her teas i can go use
for a you know
lime you know gatorade like drink that i
could print out or i might even be able
to print a drink that
you know somebody creates somebody on
the on the internet just creates a
recipe and then my printer can just
print that recipe out and i can try that
drink at home and so instead of
shipping you know cans of beverages or
going to a store where there's beverages
on a shelf and then i drive it home and
i put it on my shelf instead of that
whole process
we just combine the water that we
already have in our homes with a like
kind of like a printer cartridge of
flavors and you can print whatever drink
you want so all right tell me tell me if
i butchered it you did great i love the
use cases those are those are perfect
and awesome so that was great
and i mean i think that's exactly right
i mean you know the the big
discovery the big kind of aha with this
business
is based on the idea that 99 of
beverages are water
or maybe water plus sugar or maybe water
plus alcohol and one only one percent of
all beverages is
the chemistry that makes the flavor the
smell
uh the color and the texture of the
beverage and that one percent
is all that we really need to turn water
into all these different beverages
so the capital water into wine
water into wine what canada by the way
is the town in galilee where jesus
turned water into wines uh that's the
name
little known fact now now now becoming a
better known fact
um but uh friends that went to sunday
school by the way tend to know that um
but basically uh you know if you take a
wine wine has about 500 of those flavor
compounds that's all the stuff that
comes from the grape and the skin and
the you know the branch and the the
leaves and the oak and all the stuff
and it turns out that of those 500
compounds chemically speaking only about
30 to 40 really matter to your sensory
palate so your nose and mouth can only
really pick up and and really cares
about the 30 to 40 compounds the same is
true in coffee in tea in juice in soda
in liquor in beer so all of these
beverages are 99 water or water and
sugar and alcohol and one percent are
compounds where you might have hundreds
of compounds in the organic state
uh but you really only need a few dozen
of them and when you look at the
chemical
composition it turns out that that few
dozen compounds can be very overlapping
from one beverage to the other only a
few tweaks of a few chemicals can change
a white wine into a red one or you know
chardonnay to a soft block and so the
idea is like let's get those compounds
those ingredients into a cartridge just
like an inkjet printer where you might
have cmyk right four colors and we could
have 80 compounds and we think that with
80 compounds
we can recreate all the beverage flavors
that make up you know everything from an
oj to a gatorade to a beer to an iced
tea to an iced coffee
uh to a margarita
and so that's the idea with the business
and so you know we're canada.com just
launched right so it's um we're going to
be
we spent about three years on this
project first was all the chemical work
so you know does the chemistry make
sense can we actually decompose all the
beverages so we've at this point use
though what's called a gcms or a gas
chromatography mass spectrometer to to
analyze what are the molecular
um components of literally thousands of
beverages it's like 23 and b for drinks
yeah
yeah and it's like this is
um this is really scanning the world's
um or digitizing the world's beverages
and so we've got all the sodas all the
bottles of wine all the liquor all the
tequila everything you can come up with
has gone through this device
and then based on that chemical
composition we've built software that
uses heuristics or master combinations
to try and reduce the number of
compounds down and create a common
overlapping set that we can recreate all
the beverages so give me the origin
story so were you just sitting around
one day and you're like you know what
all these drinks are 99 water and then
just one percent is the differentiation
why don't i do like how does an idea
like this even come into your brain what
do you see what are you reading what
what happened where did the epiphany
happen
well a couple things one is i had a good
sense for that for a while
um i was at dinner with a professor from
uc davis um back in
late 2019 or so
and um
uh
and so or 2018 uh 2019 and so he was
telling me about this research paper
published by the scientist in germany at
the technical university of munich and
this the scientist runs a flavor science
lab and he was he basically took a glass
of wine and he reduced it from 500
compounds down to like 37 or 40 or
something and gave it to a consumer
sensory panel and they couldn't tell the
difference between that wine and the
original one and then he did it with
another one another wine and he's kind
of made these declarative statements
that he thinks we could recreate all
beverages with just a few dozen
compounds
and so that was kind of i said to the
guy at dinner i'm like why don't we just
make the star trek replicator for
beverages like we could just print any
beverage if we could just get those few
dozen compounds to people's homes um and
so there's a guy working with us as a
scientist in residence at tbb which is a
foundry we run kind of r d programs
internally and if we feel confident that
the r d yields an opportunity we'll
build a business around it so in this
particular case we said hey lance why
don't we read these papers try and
recreate these experiments and see if we
can come up with a good orientation
around is it really feasible that we can
create thousands of beverages using just
a few dozen compounds that they make
economic sense that we can put them in a
flavor cartridge and turn this into a
machine
and so
you know after about a year year and a
half we actually you know convinced
ourselves that this is going to work we
separately ran a chemistry program
analytical chemistry program as well as
a um
hardware program and um you know we had
uh spreadsheet models that showed that
the math could work and that we could
actually make this device and we we had
a bunch of different technical
challenges on how do you actually
dispense right you know microliter and
submicroliter volumes of these flavoring
compounds into the water stream you got
to make sure you can do the whole thing
in 15 seconds or 20 seconds because
otherwise consumers are gonna get
annoyed it's gotta taste incredible you
can't you gotta have high precision it's
gotta be cheap you gotta make it really
cold i mean all the the product that you
know we had all these prds we were
trying to iterate on and then we yield
our kind of estimated cost model and
then we have to prove the tech work so
you know very iterative cycle for the
last three years to get to this point so
we now have fully working prototypes of
the uh the gen one of the device uh
we're going to production on the gen 1
of the device and hope to ship early
next year
um and so we're starting pre-orders
today
um for uh for 99 you can uh reserve a
fully refundable 99 reservation fee and
the first 10 000 orders are 10 or 4.99
for the device and 7.99 after the first
10 000. so that's the setup so let me
just let me do two things i want to
first ask about the kind of like what
kind of drinks am i going to be able to
get out of this just what what the
average person wants to know and then
secondly i want to talk about the impact
of that because i think my sense is that
if you're making the device if you're
making what you what you eat and drink
in your own home
like literally you're producing in your
own home you cut out a bunch of trucking
storage packaging stuff that doesn't
need to happen that might actually help
the environment so i want to talk about
the environment in a second um but let's
first do the fun stuff so the drinks
okay so
um
i got water in my house and uh you can
your drinks are gonna be you have a way
to basically cool down the water or and
can you like carbonate it or what are
the limitations here yep it's it's
chilled and carbonated uh optional
obviously in the device you don't need
to worry about any of that or you can go
hot um uh we don't do heating so we
don't do a hot hot beverages in gen one
so just to be clear you're not gonna
have hot coffee or hot tea uh but there
is cold brew there is iced teas flavored
iced teas all that there's a whole
variety of stuff there
um but the idea is uh there are three
cartridges so there's the master flavor
cartridge you put it in it should last
anywhere from one to three months um
before you need to kind of replace it uh
there's a sugar cartridge because a lot
of beverages people want to have sugar
and so there's a separate cartridge for
sugar should last about a month and a
separate cartridge for alcohol should
last about a month um and you don't have
to buy cartridges they're free they
auto-ship to your home and you just put
them in when they arrive
the device senses when you're running
low and we send you a new cartridge we
charge per drink so um the the price per
drink is going to be
25 to 50 on average cheaper than what
you would pay in retail for that same
beverage um so uh you know at the end of
each month your car your account is
charged for the beverages you consume
but you don't need to go to the store
you don't need to buy cartridges you
don't need to deal with all the nonsense
we take care of all that it's really
supposed to be hassle-free
and then the idea is there's beverages
that range from morning till night so
iced coffee iced tea
sparkling you know soda uh
juice um uh uh hydration or energy
drinks there's um
uh heart seltzers cocktails wine
um and so there's a range of kind of
add-ons and features like there's
caffeination there's uh nutrient boost
so you can actually vitamin boost those
electrolyte boosts and so you could have
low alcohol hard seltzer you could have
low sugar
juice for your kids you could have um
you know add caffeine have an extra
boost of caffeine or low caffeine
iced tea so there's there's all this
variation around what you can do
ultimately from a personalization
perspective and as a user what you're
going to experience is
literally hundreds or thousands of
brands available to you on this device
and they're all going to be new brands
so we're not yet revealing who the
brands are
i think we're a few of them will start
to announce this week
but if you think about where this goes
as a consumer today you really have a
very limited number of choices when it
comes to brands because there's only
about 150 slots in a retail store for
wine beer coffee tea juice soda
and so you know minute maid coca-cola
pepsi seven up these are nameless
faceless corporate brands
in the future
you're going to have your own brand
right so you and your podcast can make a
branded beverage put it on canada and
your followers can buy your beverage and
it can be your favorite blueberry heart
seltzer or your wife's favorite tea
and she's kind of you know and so you
guys can build your own brands at a cost
of nothing to you
um and so i think that the future is a
lot like what we saw in media where
people are consuming tick tock and
youtube and netflix and you know there's
a long tale of content there's a long
tale of things that are associated with
individuals now and influencers i think
the same will happen in brands yeah so
basically just to kind of explain that
again because i think it's an important
point so you're saying you know the same
way that
if you wanted to you know watch tv or
listen to the radio there was just a
fixed number of slots and so
they you know when there was three
channels well they would show the most
general thing that would appeal to like
kind of the common denominator type of
audience and then when we got cable we
got more channels so now you got a
fishing channel and a golf channel but
you know those are still
pretty broad actually when you compare
to youtube where it's like i can watch
somebody who just likes to binge eat
food and like that's just what i want to
watch right now i can watch a guy who
you know some crossfit thing that may
not have made it onto espn espn2 espn3
or espn you know like it would have
never made it
you can't you can't binge watch chess
matches on espn but you can on youtube
right so you're now watching way more
more media than you would have otherwise
because you love chess matches this
podcast is a good example not only does
it give the consumer more choice it
gives the creator a way to just push a
button and try their hand at it and if
we're good like we okay we kind of
sucked at the beginning and now we're
good now we get a few million downloads
a month well that's great because we it
was permissionless nobody had we didn't
have to go audition anywhere and um and
get selected in order to be on stage so
what you're saying is the same thing is
going to happen in drinks so the
consumer's gonna have this infinite
selection of like flavors that fit their
needs so the low sugar orange juice
you know whatever that the sparkling
whatever that's gonna be appealing to
that person they're gonna be able to
print that beverage even though it may
not be sold on this on the shelves
because it's not the not like kind of
mass popular uh drink choice and the
other thing is me and sam have already
started brainstorming sam also do a root
beer i'm interested in more of like a
sparkling water sort of thing a
non-alcohol like refreshing thing no so
we're you know let's do it you got you
guys want to do it no i'm serious yeah
we want to do it yeah so come to redwood
city try the device and we'll get you
guys set up and you make your own brand
and that's the question right we were we
were about and people got started dming
us because they were like yeah dude we
were told because we were we we like to
make up fake name brands on this on the
show we're like oh southern sam's root
beer and then you know sean's you know
whatever motivation i like to i said
this idea i said somebody should make a
brand of water that's just called lucky
water and just it's just a little you
might have good luck if you drink with
water so i don't have lucky water right
it's placebo water and just say there is
no this is a total placebo but hey it
never hurts and um and so you can put a
hint of something in there just a hint
well it's gonna have some flavor but you
know
the luck is why so anyways that's my
drink and so but the question was this
is gonna taste the same right so for
example i lived in china for a bunch of
years and you would get these sodas and
there's this phrase for expats living in
china called nqr not quite right where
it's like it almost tastes like kfc but
like it doesn't taste like kfc totally
that was a common problem when they
tried to export these kind of flavors to
another country so i know you're kind of
biased but give me the you seem like
you're pretty honest guy i don't think
you're trying to sell stuff no i mean
we're pretty technical about so so
here's an important point and i made
this point earlier today um so it's
fresh on my mind there's a difference
between taste and flavor
flavor is the sensory experience that
you have um you know biochemically and
biologically as you experience a a bunch
of chemistry in your mouth
um
taste
is how you psychologically or how your
brain interprets and and finds that
appealing so we've all heard stories
about taking expensive wine and cheap
wine and blindfolding people and giving
it to them they can't tell the the
difference i can give you really cheap
two buck chuck in a two michelin star
restaurant you taste it and you're like
oh my gosh this is amazing you know
fantastic i can give you really
expensive wine at mcdonald's and you
kind of chug it down right and so um
taste is a function of the overall kind
of sensory experience when you have a
product when you engage in a product and
so um you know a big part of what we're
trying to get right
is that experience being more than just
the flavor we have to get
right right like but you have to make
sure that there's something to
substitute for the affinity you have
with a brand so you have an affinity
with kfc or coca-cola and so there's
some benefit of that being ingrained in
your mind you taste something it's good
enough you're like okay cool
um and so what we do from a flavor so so
that's number one is there's a whole
digital experience on the device that we
think is really important brands no
longer are static it's not just a logo
brands are visual right so so there's a
video or some audio that comes through
as you're exploring as you're trying
stuff through the device um
and then um
flavor it's really straightforward
our chemistry team prints beverages we
take the best in the market for that
category so we'll take sprite lemon lime
soda we'll print one of our lemon lime
sodas and we have a sensory panel where
we bring in consumers they blind taste
and we score stuff and then we get
iterative feedback on what's working
what's not and that allows us to craft
formulize so um you know that is a big
part of our analytical chemistry process
is the sensory feedback that we do blind
and so we don't graduate formulai we
don't say that these ingredients work
until and unless we hit and exceed best
in market comparables by the way really
interesting statistic you'll see
that um things like cold brew coffee
which is a really interesting one
because it's so complex and can be so
different just like dark chocolate you
can take like starbucks and blue bottle
and one group of people will
passionately love starbucks one group of
people will passionately love blue
bottle and so you know you'll see that
our sk we will score
really well with one group with one of
our formula and really well with the
other group with another one of our
formulae and so this goes to the point
earlier if you take a coca-cola it's got
44 grams of sugar or whatever in it
that's what coca-cola decided was gonna
be the lowest common denominator that's
how they get the biggest audience to buy
coca-cola but it turns out some people
would buy more coca-cola if it was 20
grams of sugar and some people would buy
more coca-cola if it was 60 grams of
sugar so if coca-cola had a 20 gram 30
gram 40 gram 50 gram and 60 gram version
of coca-cola they would sell a lot more
in aggregate of all those virgins than
if they sold just the 144 grams sugar
and so sugar is a terrible example
because it's evil and awful but we all
love it um but you know they're like my
point is from that has a yeah on this
you've seen that one that malcolm
gladwell has his ted talk about the the
perfect pasta sauce is it's not like
there's millions of years yeah yeah you
got to listen to this thing so malcolm
gladwell goes on and like in his style
he goes and he tells this great story
about this this guy that gets hired by
pepsi by coke and then gets hired by
prego i think it is he's like we want
the perfect pasta sauce what is the
perfect flavor for consumers and he
discovers there is no perfect pasta
sauce there are only perfect pasta
sauces he's like that's right some
people want the chunky one and there is
a perfect version of the chunky that
will appeal to the most people there and
then some people want the one that's
this and that's why you see the aisle
today and there's like the the one
that's super garlicky and then there's
the one that's super chunky and then
there's one that's not chunky because
those people feel very passionately that
chunky is better than non-chunky it's
not close for them and then you know
another group of people will feel the
exact opposite and so but they're
limited in some ways because they're
those are still
well they're only going to bottle five
of these or seven of these or 12 of
these and put them on shelves which can
only hold whatever seven variations
whereas you're not limited by that in
the same way that youtube's not limited
by the number of channels on your tv
that's right exactly right and i think
that's where
it's not about are we better than
coca-cola it's that can everyone find a
product on canada that they like more
than coca-cola and
you can't use their name right so what
are you gonna do are you like smoking
shmola like what how are you gonna oh no
no we're not using any any of those
brands we're it's all new brands so your
lucky water is going to be a brand we're
going to get that done okay and so
you'll find hundreds of new brands
available on canna that you don't find
on the store shelves and um and you're
going to have like your house brands
basically of the popular things
yourselves just to see we may yeah i i'm
not interested
like i'm more interested in finding
partners that are going to be passionate
promoters and want to you know be
creators on this platform so i think
that's where i'm most interested i think
we're going to have to see a bunch of
stuff ourselves but
um you know i think it's it's likely
going to be the case that folks that
want to be creators are going to be
bringing brands to market through the
device well you know this has happened
with alcohol right so like the rock i
think is i think exactly he sold i don't
know how many hundreds of thousands of
cases of his tequila like he's the rock
is gonna be a billionaire not from
wrestling not from movies but from same
with city cents same with george clooney
i mean
but you've all got beverage brands and
by the way
you have to be huge and that's the thing
so um only three percent of beverage
brands that launch
and get retail space actually make it to
10 million in sales right and so you
know if you're someone with less than
100 million followers you've only got 3
million followers you're a great youtube
creator people know you they love you
they're passionate about you you're
never going to go make a beverage brand
it's gonna cost five million dollars to
do that you gotta go make formulate it
you gotta make packaging you gotta make
a logo you gotta box it then you gotta
go convince retail stores to carry it
right i mean the whole process is like
an insurmountable process generally
speaking you have to be huge like the
rock to get that and you know there's
probably 90 000 times more people in
that middle
that are really influential have a lot
of followers aren't as big as george
clooney in the rock and so they could
make a brand that doesn't require any
investment that doesn't require any
capital they don't have to take any risk
um and look if it's digital it's
permissionless right so if it works
great like they've got
um a nice revenue stream and you give a
share so let's say
i don't what do you think the average
drink's gonna sell for like a dollar or
less than a dollar
so it ranges from you know 29 cents for
like a sparkling water like a flavored
water like a la croix competitor yeah um
up to um 2.99 for kind of like a really
nice cocktail um you know you'll find
that like a mojito or mimosa will be
like 1.99
generally the price will be about 25 to
50 percent less than the store right so
let's say i'm selling my my 30 cent uh
lucky water what is the is there a
standard out of the box like an app
store like 30 cut type of thing or what
what is the what is the business model
because because this will let more
people do the rock thing this will let
people like me do the rock thing where
we can just right formulate a drink
sell it virtually digitally into
everybody who has a printer it's now
available and then we get a small income
stream royalty stream coming through
this yeah by the way the royalty stream
for like someone like 50 cent or
something is gonna was like two to six
percent you know so
they're participating on net right and
so there's a very um
different kind of
model there we offer a much higher share
of revenue
obviously you know
this is a a very difficult business to
operate so we've got to get cartridges
made we got to get them to people's
homes we auto renew so there's a whole
services component so you know we've got
a pretty good pitch
today for brand partners um you know we
haven't launched um commercially so i'm
not going to kind of commit to what the
number is going to be but i i think it's
a really
really compelling opportunity um and
they're all going to be you know real
they're going to own their brand so if
they want to take that brand
and use it elsewhere it doesn't have to
be exclusive we don't own the brand it's
your brand right so you can take your
brand lucky water and if it takes off
and you've got 10 million people that
want to buy it in stores go launch it in
stores you know it's your brand um so
yeah i think it's a platform for letting
people kind of create and ideate and
um and you know see if they can develop
value there and it's almost like it's
like merch right like i mean just you
know monetize your yourself the the
device cost is at 4.99 or it's going to
cost 4.99 that's the pre-order kind of
for the first 10 000 orders so once we
hit 10 000 the price has gone up to 7.99
yeah and then is this the like kind of
tesla roadster model where you think
that you know where do you want to drive
this down to what do you think is the
thing you need where this actually is
not just my you know cool thing in my
house when people come over and i can do
a magic trick like when does this become
standard where it's not a magic trick
everyone's got one
so it's a it's a great question um you
know there's about 35 million keurigs
installed in the world there's like
three and a half four and a half million
soda streams
um
these devices
have prices that range from like 70
bucks up to 299 for like a nice
nespresso and then this you know so so
299 maybe gets you kind of a
10 market you know 199 gets you 30
percent i don't know the number because
part of what we're doing is we're not
just a single product in a single day
part so an espresso curricular stream
one product one day part so will people
pay more for more day parts uh will
people pay more for more variety for
lower hopefully our prices are going to
be lower
than what you pay for for some other
alternative products so the value we can
provide to consumers i think will
ultimately dictate how the market
expands as a function of price right um
and uh
and then form factor so so you know can
we get it smaller and then uh heating
can we add heating to it and so you know
there's a bunch of features on the
roadmap and then the trade-offs on price
so you know if we add heating it costs a
lot more it's going to get bigger can we
make a technology leap where we can
actually get everything to be smaller
and add heat and drop the price and you
know as we go from gen 1 we're calling
this our gen 1 device the canon one to
gen 3 we really think gen 3 ends up
being kind of like it's got everything
for everyone and it's an accessible
price point for the mass market
and i don't know if you're fully out of
time but i did want to give you a chance
to talk environment for a second if you
have it great i think that's probably
pretty major or like at least one of the
big drivers for you here pretty much all
the work we do at tpb is oriented around
how do we change systems of production
on planet earth so that um we can make
things using less energy less land less
natural resources
i'm a big believer that sustainability
in the 21st century does not arise from
convincing consumers to consume less i
think sustainability arises from
building technology-based solutions that
let consumers consume more
and dropping the price and dropping the
environmental impact and that's what
technology allows us to do so if you go
back to the industrial revolutions you
know of the 19th and 20th century we
built factories right we put all this
technology in a big machine and a big
facility and we used it to make stuff
over and over again and that dropped the
price for consumers because we automated
in a big factory turns out that the
technology of that factory as all
technology does
shrinks
gets faster gets cheaper gets better and
so theoretically technology like what
exists in a factory a technology that's
better than what exists in a factory to
make beverages can be put in your home
and so you know the idea is how do you
decentralize manufacturing because it
takes about 600 liters of water to make
a single liter of wine it takes about 40
liters of water to make a liter of
orange juice and we take all of this
water and by the way orange juice is 93
water 7 sugar only 1 percent is the
flavor compounds right wine is 88 water
11 alcohol less than one percent flavor
compounds so you know how do we so we've
taken all this water grown all these
crops that basically turn into water put
them into glass and plastic and cans
that we use carbon dioxide to make then
we put them on trucks which use carbon
dioxide to go to warehouses that then go
into stores then go into your home and
then you store them in your home and
you're basically drinking water and
every industrialized home has water it's
about half a billion tons of co2 that
are put into the atmosphere every year
to make bottled cans and beverages um it
is about a bottle bottled and canned
beverages it is about
400 trillion liters of water that are
used in the whole production cycle of
bottled beverages um and consumers are
spending 2.3 trillion dollars a year on
this archaic insane system of
centralized manufacturing to use a ton
of energy and a ton of carbon and a ton
of land to just move water into your
home when you already have water in your
home 120 million acres of farmland that
could be reduced and returned back to
the uh natural ecosystems that we would
stop using to grow all this stuff so
that's our long-term incentive right the
incentive is can we take that carbon out
of the atmosphere can we reduce the
waste on water can we return the land to
natural ecosystems and at the same time
make a cheaper and better experience for
consumers by decentralizing
manufacturing and putting these devices
in homes and giving people better
options
and so that's why we're so excited about
this you know i think i think we we have
an opportunity to do something that has
an impact but also hopefully gives
consumers something that's better than
what they have today
yeah
i don't know if you're hiring but this
is one of those companies where i would
look at i'd say wow that'd be a cool
place to work if i was out there in the
job market because you have
hard tech problem you have a device that
if it works it's going to be like
a household name yeah everybody's going
to know it it's going to be like a
netflix or an ipod or something it's
going to be something that everybody
knows if this actually pulls it off i
mean you're on some willy wonka you
know you're basically creating this
magical device that lets you create
whatever you want you know your own
little candy your own little beverage
in your home i think that's uh
it's pretty inspiring and uh and you
know to do that while also
having a big impact on the environment
right like most people would look at
that environmental supply chain you
talked about and say how do we make this
20 more efficient at this step how do we
make the trucks emit a little less
carbon dioxide right how do we how do we
just reduce this by 15
and what you've done is said why are we
doing this in the first place why don't
we eliminate the whole chain so why are
we using all this water and all this
plastic and all this fuel just to move
water from here to there and add a
little bit of flavor to it all right the
water and totally
even even worse when there's already
water piped into people's homes so we
already built the the core
infrastructure the pipe into the home
with water all we gotta do is sort of
like at the last last mile not even last
mile sort of like the last two feet of
counter space just converted into the
product people want so i think
yeah and like all the refrigerator space
and energy to run the refrigerator to
store all that stuff and like the
the stuff in your in your cabinets yeah
so that's exactly right i mean you
nailed it like that's why it's so
awesome so yeah we are hiring and we got
great offices so and people go to work
in the office and so
uh that's a perk nowadays
you can see humans if you work with us
yeah you know i'm gonna go out i'm gonna
meet people irl i think you know climate
corp is cool the insurance companies are
yeah it's not that cool but you know i
guess you made some money this is cool
this is gonna be your biggest thing
hopefully this will be the thing that
you know college version of you would be
like all right that was that was sweet
not not underwhelmed by that one uh as
long as my as long as my kids are proud
down the road i'll be happy so that's
all good all right tell people where to
go to uh so canada.com go go
canada.coma.com and um yeah you can
check out the product specs and the the
product video and and sign up
uh for a 99 pre-order reservation thanks
for coming on man i really appreciate
this i'm a fan of yours it's been
awesome to chat yeah it's been a great
chat i think you really really nailed it
and i appreciate you you listening so
that's been great thank you
[Music]